hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice classical game from the interpolis
fifth Tournament of 1981 it was played
in Netherlands and we have Gary Kasparov
versus tigran petrozian so a future
world champion against a former world
champion and I thought this game was
really incredible I I saw it on Twitter
not the exact game I actually saw an
imagined position from this game they
tweaked it a little bit to fit the
puzzle but then I thought uh I've never
actually seen this game and then when I
saw the game I saw why it was um so
impressive so it was from round seven of
this event and just shows you what what
a wild attacker caspara was always like
from from a very early age until the you
know his very last days is an active
player and uh on the other hand what uh
what a monster Defender uh former world
champion tigran Petrosian was so let's
dive straight into it casparov has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 and
you guys will have a great opportunity
to finish a masterpiece in this game
with Ponte D5 uh C4 uh going for the
Queen's Gambit uh tigrant accepts the
Queen's Gambit as one always should and
now Knight to F3 we have Knight to F6
and now Pawn to E3 so going after the C4
Pawn uh and here we have Bishop to G4
here the the absolute main line is spawn
to E6 Bishop to G4 is the second most
popular one but obviously still very
popular Bishop captures on C4 and pawn
to E6 we have Pawn to H3 challenging the
bishop hoping for Bishop captures Queen
captures but of course Pawn to H5 we
have Knight to C3 by Gotti and pawn to
A6 grabbing the B5 Square we have Pawn
to G for Bishop G6 and now Knight to E5
just putting pressure on the bishop here
Knight B to D7 and now Knight captures
and G6 with age captures and now Bishop
back to F1 so this is still a main
Theory even in 2023 we have Pawn to C6
of course tigranos that the bishop is
now coming to this diagonal uh Bishop to
G2 and queen to C7 tigran is now
repairing the castle Queen side uh
Kasparov cast of King's side uh Bishop
to D2 still a bit more popular today but
castles obviously still very strong and
Bishop to E7 and it is now as of move 13
that this position has never been
reached again after it was played here
in round 7 of this very nice game so
okay Kasparov strikes with Pawn to F4
and grabs full control of the center uh
prepares Pawn to G5 and now Knight to B6
we have Pawn to G5 and Knight F the D7
and now Queen to G4 a very annoying move
for tigrant to face uh not only an
active Square for the queen but also if
Tyran perhaps decides the castle King
side then kasparo would just go H for H5
open up the the king side maybe even you
know bring the Rook to the H file and
try to do some damage as the bishop has
not been fiend Caro de Bishop is an E7
so this would be a deadly attack so
instead we have Castle's Queen side and
now Rook to B1 of course kaspar prepares
the pawn to B4 as he is a great attacker
with King the B8 and now Pawn to B4 and
I'll just Knight the 5 tigran as uh you
know he is definitely a cold-blooded
Defender he he will just grab that B5
Pawn uh before pawn and not care about
giving as part of the semi-open B file
to be used for attack so Knights the A4
gas power of uh looks at those dark
squares he uh you know uh wants to
create some future outposts and now Pawn
to F5 while a great move for tigran it
really prevents him from opening up the
king's side anytime soon so upon to F5
win the G3 now because power will uh
figure out a way how to bring that Queen
into the attack on the queen side and
just Knight captures on B4 just a
cold-blooded Knight captures and be
forgiving has part of the semi-open B
file to attack Bishop to D2 attacks the
Knight and tigran just goes back Knight
to D5 also an excellent Outpost for the
Knight it's very well defended and it
sort of diminishes the power of the
bishop and G2 with Rook F to C1 and now
King to A7 just getting the King off of
the uh the B file so he doesn't have to
worry about any any tricks uh Queen to
E1 uh and now Bishop to A3 first
harassing The Rook here Rook to C2 and
now Queen to D6 now with full control
over this
um uh B4 Square now the bishop Queen and
Knight are controlling it and now comes
Rook to B3 now Kasparov has uh has to
figure out a plan and he figures out how
to maximize the activity of his pieces
he will play Rook to B3 which puts
pressure on the bishop and then he will
play Queen to E2 to D3 but Queen to E2
is also a very tricky move not just
because it will kick away the Bishop
from A3 but he also wants to play Queen
E2 and Bishop to F1 to put pressure on
the A6 Pawn with some ideas of playing
Rook capture some B7 sacrificing The
Rook for a deadly attack so tigran has
to be aware of all of this with Queen
back to E7 now the queen also will serve
as a Defender to the to the B Pawn and
the seventh Rank and now Queen to EQ
casparova starts mobilizing his pieces
Rook to B8 and now Queen to D3 now the
bishop has to move Bishop back to D6 and
now Knight to B2 now the Knight is no
longer useful here kasparo wants to
shift it over to C4 which where it will
be much stronger so Knight B2 and now
Rook H the C8 we have knighted the C4
and now just Bishop to C7 so if you look
at this position it doesn't look like a
position you would want to have uh well
especially if if uh if you're playing
against Gary Kasparov look at the Rooks
here absolutely incredible look at the
bishop here on this diagonal look at the
queen here on this diagonal the Knight
here ready to wreak havoc so what what
is the next move I want the A4 of course
preparing the counter B5 but now you
will see what a great defender means uh
A4 to stop B5 but tigran plays B5
nonetheless and now how how does this
work you want to keep your king safe but
uh you know tigrant just advances the
pawn in the Pawns in front of his King a
captures on B5 and now C captures and 5
puts pressure on the Knight here and
casparov prepares a deadly trap he plays
Rook to A2 and now look at this position
how do you evaluate this who is uh who
who is doing what here uh can the Knight
be captured well for the moment no if
you capture the Knight then casparov had
this beautiful Rook captures an A6 plant
and if King captures then Queen captures
and C4 check and now you just get
checkmated Queen A4 check only move
Bishop A5 and queen captures and A5 will
be Checkmate so what is tigernon's idea
here how how is he to defend King the B7
now there's no other word when when uh
talking about Tigres games other than
cold-blooded like he just doesn't Flinch
so just came to B7 and now how do you
continue here this is a a such a crazy
position that is actually winning for
Kasparov but we're gonna get back to
this position because it's too important
to discuss it now because power plays
Bishop to B4 now he wants to attack the
queen and grab full control over the D6
square and then he will continue the
attack so of course the queen has to
move you don't have time for B captures
on C4 to attack the White Queen because
Bishop captures an E7 comes with checks
so you just blunder a queen there so he
moves the queen to E8 and knock as far
plays Bishop to D6 now of course the
Knight cannot be captured and the
Bishops cannot be traded off because
just Knight captures with a monster Fork
here uh so here Rook to A8 again only
only tigan can uh decipher his moves uh
we have Queen to be won by Kasparov now
with some ideas even of Queen captures
uh here and now comes the only move that
uh keeps Tigra in the game and that is
King to C6 and when you see such a move
and the these are only the kind of moves
that tigran would find uh he's actually
threatening to capture your peace with
the king the threat is the simple Bishop
captures and then Knight captures and
King captures and D6 and you don't have
uh I mean there's just no good way to
play this so if you go back Bishop day
three then the Knight is of course uh up
for grabs there's no way to continue the
attack uh and uh the best way to play
for Kasparov is just to call it a day
and play Bishop captures on C7 and here
absolutely everything gets traded down B
captures and C4 Rook to B7 and now after
Rook captures and C7 even Rook captures
an A6 with check freeing up the B5
Square for the White Queen Rook capture
Sun A6 Queen to B5 check King to D6 now
you captured this Rook with the check
King goes to E7 now you remove the
defender of the rook and C7 so Bishop
captures on D5 Rook captures on B7 and
Bishop captures on B7 and you get this
position where it's equal material
Bishop against the Knight tigram would
have a past Pawn on on C4 but his king
would be a bit more vulnerable so all in
all a fairly equal position but after
King to C6 Kasparov lost the threat of
the game and he played Rook B to A3 he
felt that maybe the the attack was still
happening because who who could actually
calculate this and now tigran just plays
B captures and C for just another
cold-blooded capture no way to uh to you
know do any Mind Tricks antigrant now
comes with Rook captures and A6 with
check Rook captures and now Rook
captures an A6 with check and now just
Bishop the B6 how do you continue Bishop
to C5 of course you put pressure on the
B6 Bishop as you are now ready to start
capturing as the the Knight and D5
cannot move but now Queen to d8 just
adding the defender to the bishop
absolutely incredible Queen day one by
Kasparov and now Knight captures and C5
with d captures and C5 and even King
captures on C5 look at this uh brave
brave black king and here because
Sparrow played Rook to A4 but it was
also in this position and move 42 that
Kasparov resigned in the game as there
is nothing more to be done here he's
just done too much material and there's
no way to continue the attack Tegan can
even play something like King to B5 that
doesn't really matter any move ethereum
plays is perfectly fine and if you
continue checking Queen A3 check King to
C6 and if you play Queen T for check
even King to B7 there is no way to
continue the attack and the bishop here
well it's absolutely useless just the
pawn on E6 is defending the Knight and
the queen is is perfectly fine after
this Rook day for move kasparo resigned
and there is nothing more
that could be done here but what uh what
have happens if we go back just a little
bit to the position that we discussed
where kaspar prepared this deadly attack
with Rook day too you know remember the
one where we sacrifice the rook and
Checkmate the black king uh tigan found
this incredible King to B7 move and now
I said that the position is actually
winning for Kasparov but it's such a
uh such a tricky move to find uh but you
guys you know you are here to finish
Gary's Masterpiece feel free to pause
the video and try to find a winning idea
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on defeating a
former World chess champion tigran
petrozian in a in a brilliant brilliant
attack and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is not Pawn to
E4 but actually Queen to B1 Queen to B1
is the deadly move here I'm just gonna
briefly mention Ponte E4 because it's
actually the variation that I believe
the uh whoever posted it on Twitter used
sort of as a hypothetical line in order
how uh Kasparov could have won this but
the problem is after F captures and
queen captures okay you are threatening
a very nasty Checkmate now if tigram
plays let's say something like Queen T8
then you you actually do have this
beautiful uh Queen sacrifice Queen
captures on D5 check he captures Bishop
captures and D5 check and after King the
A7 which is tyran's only move now you
finish it off by sacrificing The Rook as
well Rook characters on A6 King captures
Rook the A3 check only moves Bishop to
A5 and now Rook captures on a 5 will be
Checkmate but this is not possible
because after you capture an E4 you can
just play Queen to F7 and now the Knight
is sufficiently defended there is no
Queen captures on D5 and the game simply
continues white is still better but it's
not uh you know it's not a game over so
the move you had to find after this King
the B7 move by tigran was Queen to B1
and now if you look at the position it
is much much different now you don't
have all the tricks that tigran used
with his King to escape now for example
let's say you play what is the thread
behind Queen to B1 well it's a fairly
obvious one let's say you play Queen F7
or something let's say you add more
defense to the D5 Knight Rook captures
on B5 is the threat and now after a
captors and queen captures with check
you're gonna block with Knight to B6
remember this Knight on D5 cannot move
now comes Knight to the A5 check and
that's just it so after King th7 You're
Gonna Play Knight to C6 check King to B7
and now uh Rook the A7 will be Checkmate
uh it's not that simple obviously if it
was that simple kaspara would find it
after Queen to B1 of course tigran will
not play a silly move like Queen the E8
that was just to show you what the
threat behind King to the queen to B1
was a tignan would find the absolute
strongest uh move and that is to move
the Rook rook d8 and now he frees up the
C8 Square for his King so how is this to
be continued now comes kasparo's move
Bishop to B4 so in the actual game
Kasparov started with Bishop to B4 and
then he played Queen to B1 but then it
was a bit different as king had time to
run away to C6 but here after Bishop to
B for now Queen to d8 now comes Knight
to B2 and now this silent move is the
move you actually had to find now the
Knight is coming to C5 and there's just
no good move for for tignan to make like
let's say Rook to 8 because of course
you will also be putting pressure on the
eighth A6 Pawn Rook to A8 now Knights
the D3 and if Bishop to B6 to try and
cover the C5 Square uh you don't care
now you play Bishop to D6 and if Rook
d7s tigran is without a move here here
now you'll play Queen to A1 now the
Knight doesn't have to come to C5 then I
can also come to B4 and put even more
pressure on A6 so the position is just
much much better for white but you have
to play incredibly precise moves Knight
the B8 to cover the A6 square but now
you go in for the kill Knight C5 check
Bishop captures D captures also defends
the bishop here and after not only that
the opponent G7 is hanging as well so
Queen to D7 and now Rook captures on B5
with check of course you cannot capture
because the Rook captures a wheel uh win
the queen so you have to play Queen
captures but now Rook to B2 uh wins the
black queen and of course you're not
gonna capture the queen You're Gonna
Play Knights to D7 but now comes an even
deadlier move Queen to A4 look at this
and now if Queen captures Rook then you
play Queen captures on D7 with check and
if King Day 8 now you just finish off
with an ice queen captures 98 checking
the B7 Queen to D7 checking date and now
Queen to C8 with check forcing The Black
Queen to go back and queen captures and
B8 will be checkmate so after this queen
day for move of course you're not going
to capture The Rook here you're gonna
play King to A8 and now of course
there's nothing more to be done here you
simply go for material Rook captures on
B5 a captures on B5 and queen captures
on B5 uh so what uh what can be played
here absolutely nothing Rook the C8 can
be played now come C6 you chase away the
Knight Knight the B8 C7 and that's it no
more moves for for tigran if Knight to
A6 then you play Queen to C6 check of
course you have to block this now Queen
captures an A6 with check you have to
block this and now Queen captures and C8
with Checkmate so this is only uh one of
the line but I decided to show you the
line with the absolute strongest
defensive moves for black as I'm pretty
sure those those are the ones that
tigron would find as he pretty much
defends like an engine if you've seen
those King moves uh it's still very much
a winning forecast Sparrow but after
King to B7 Kasparov saw it he he had uh
he he knew what he had to do he knew
that Bishop to be foreign Queen to B1
were the keys to solving the position
only he you know switched the move order
it's it's actually Queen to B1 followed
by Bishop to B for not Bishop to B for
followed by Queen to B1 but I guess you
know a great attacker like a sparrow of
that he was he thought it you know the
importance of the B2 square is uh is not
to be overlooked uh he he thought he had
to start with the B4 square and that's
why he probably started with Bishop to
B4 uh but yeah a great game by both of
them great attack by Kasparov sadly for
him he did not finish his Masterpiece
but what an incredible defensive game by
by tigran petrozian and like I said this
was played in 1981 so 10 years after the
great candidates tournament or basically
candidates matches of 1971 where Bobby
Fischer faced tiger and petrozian and if
you remember Fisher absolutely
demolished tigran with um uh losing only
one game it started like Fisher one
first game then tigran retaliated in the
second one then three games were drawn
and then Fisher just defeated Tyran by
winning four games in a row so it was uh
you know a massacre and uh well one
could say that tigern was much stronger
in 1971 than in 1981 so you know just
also puts perspective on how how strong
Bobby Fischer was and
um well here kasparo was this is still a
yankas power it will be another four
years before caspara becomes world
champion he was still honing his um you
know uh blade uh you know sharpening his
blade holding his attacking skill uh and
well you all know what happened in
1985 but yeah if you guys are interested
in the standings of this tournament as I
mean back in those days all the old
tournaments were great all the games
were very interesting uh this is um how
the turn intended uh so world champion
Anatoly carpool was not participating in
this one it was actually won by
Alexander
tigran got second place with 7 out of 11
then you have live sport is
passkey yeah with five and a half so not
the best tournament for Kasparov uh but
you know not a terrible one if you
consider the uh the the competition here
and back then uh I I pulled the rankings
off of a an old fide page uh uh kaspara
was uh number five in the world with
Boris passkey at 26.30 uh I think only
carpool was 2700 the only one rated
number one and uh yeah I thought you
guys would enjoy the old ratings as well
and I don't know uh sometimes I color
the photo sometimes I leave them black
as black and white as they were made in
the original do you guys prefer it when
I color them do you guys prefer when I
keep them black and white also something
I would very much enjoy hearing because
I don't mind coloring them but some of
you say that you prefer me not coloring
them so you know either way it's fine
for me I actually don't mind it if you
guys prefer the colored ones uh so yeah
an incredible attacker versus probably
the greatest Defender Of All Times
tigran petrozian this this is what
happened I thought this would be a nice
game to show so hope you enjoyed that so
I once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
and Amanda Oliver the most beautiful
girl in the world for her contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day